so the CEO of YouTube Susan Wojcicki
recently made some statements that lots
of people have fallen for just hook line
& sinker and I want to explain to you
today because this is so important that
what she's saying is actually that for
independent producers of news and
politics on YouTube it's about to get
much much worse what's happened already
is only going to get worse and a lot of
people are not understanding this and I
want to lay it out for you so let me lay
this out for you I've been behaving and
not talking about YouTube issues for
weeks at this point but now that she's
made these statements I really have to
talk about them so I hope you'll give me
some some leeway here because this is
important stuff Susan Wojcicki is being
lauded for saying that it's quote more
important than ever that people should
be allowed to upload anything they want
at any time to YouTube Wow
free speech diversity of voices YouTube
is turning the corner things are going
to get better for everybody including
for independent producers like us and
many of our colleagues wrong okay let me
break this down for you because you
really have to read sort of between the
lines and in context to understand what
it is that Susan Wojcicki is announcing
here she wrote a letter to creators a
few days ago and she as the CEO of
YouTube said a few things number one she
again said preserving an open platform
is more important than ever that the
problematic content is a really small
piece of what's uploaded to YouTube that
they are working to reduce that even
further and that it is more important
than ever that anyone get to upload
whatever they want of course assuming
that it is not illegal content and this
was interpreted by many and dozens of
people in my audience emailed me saying
David look Susan Wojcicki is saying it's
gonna be great you're gonna do fine your
content is going to be prioritized and
monetized and all of this stuff this is
not what Susan Wojcicki is saying the
headlines are just gushing about how
great this is the reality is that being
able to upload anything you want deals
not at all with monetization and deals
not at all
with D prioritization the two things
that independent news producers like the
David Pakman show have been facing the
issue for independent producers like us
is not that at any point there was a
question about whether I'd be able to
upload whatever I want whenever I want
that was never the issue the issues are
the speech limiting force of D
monetization on uploads deemed
controversial by YouTube and the D
prioritization of independent news
content in favor of legacy corporate
news content and that's actually going
to get worse whiskey goes on to say in
this letter that people are just like
blindly gushing about she says we raise
up as as part of the commitment that she
is now making she says we raise up
authoritative voices when people are
looking for breaking news and
information this is an announcement
where she is saying we are going to even
more prioritize so-called authoritative
voices at the expense of non
authoritative voices which as we know
means CNN's YouTube channel and MSNBC's
and Fox News's YouTube channels and
late-night talk shows with tens of
millions of dollar production budgets at
the expense of the David Pakman show and
Sam cedar and Kyle kolinsky and all of
the others this is what happened already
the announcement is saying we are going
to do more of what we've been doing for
the last year we're going to keep
letting you upload whatever you want
whenever you want as she says but what
we're gonna promote to the audience is
authoritative news content meaning
corporate media so let me remind you
because this is not me saying this is
going to happen this has happened it's
happening already last summer
YouTube said for the first time in news
and politics we are going to be pushing
authoritative sources more within weeks
YouTube's algorithm took away about two
to two and a half million views per
month from us through what's called the
recommended view algorithm as you can
see on screen right after YouTube made
this a noun
around the time YouTube made this
announcement about pushing authoritative
news we were getting about three and a
half million views per month just from
the recommended view algorithm meaning
you're watching something else and
YouTube says hey you might like to check
out this clip of the david pakman show
from 3.5 million to just 1.5 million in
the last few months and in June barely 1
million of those views this is a
shortfall this is what Susan Wojcicki is
cheering about we're pushing and
prioritizing authoritative content for
us that has so far met a shortfall of
two to two and a half million views per
month since YouTube first announced this
2 million views per month as a shortfall
as just the snap of the fingers it's
gone is a lot of revenue for us it adds
up very very quickly and now Susan
Wojcicki is hiding in what is being
framed as a beautiful positive letter of
love to creators they are once again
going to keep pushing corporate
authoritative news sources so-called
authoritative news sources this is a
disaster for channels like ours and the
latest by the way is that something in
the YouTube algorithm now is hurting new
subscriber numbers as well if you look
at recent new subscribers for a lot of
independent news channels including ours
daily new subscribers are all trending
down and it's not because of what any
one channel is doing because they're all
trending down I didn't pull the data
visually to show you but it's available
online you can find it so YouTube is
saying everything's great peace and love
it's all going to be wonderful and the
reality is that it's going to be more of
the same problems that we've had so
listen like I've said before the
solution here is we've just got to sever
the tie between ad dollars and
monetizing content right now the amount
of monetization we receive the amount of
revenue we receive on YouTube it depends
on does YouTube say that what we are
publishing is too controversial to run
ads if so then we don't make any money
is YouTube saying okay what you're
publishing is not too controversial but
we are going to suggest to viewers that
they look at CNN's coverage of it
or Fox News's coverage of it instead of
your coverage of it and the solution is
we've got to sever that tie
support the shows that you like directly
I don't care what shows they are if it's
not this one if you say you know David I
really what you do is okay but I think
these other five producers are much
better support them okay with us you can
support the work we do directly you can
circumvent this entire advertiser
monetization link that exists by going
to our website join pakman.com and just
getting a membership this is cheap right
we're not we're not talking about a lot
of money talking about a few bucks a
month you can use the coupon code half
19 to save 50% off of your membership
takes under a minute you get extra
content and you're supporting us you
give us insurance against these changes
that Susan Wojcicki is gleefully
announcing they're going to make you can
also make a pledge on patreon just as
quick and you might already have a
patreon account if you're supporting
other shows there at patreon.com slash
david pakman show thank you for letting
me rant we can now continue with the
show I've been good
I haven't done the YouTube stuff force
feels like it's been close to a month
probably more like three weeks but it
just had to be discussed today